l'autre soir d'écouter cette histoire
ont joué au théâtre national de l'odéon
la pièce le roi se meurt dans la salle
il y avait de tout des pauvres des
riches les snobs des paumés des japonais
l'affût de la culture occidentale canon
en bandoulière vous savez il y avait ce
bruissement d'avant le spectacle qui
marque aussi bien la peur de l'acteur
que la tante du spectateur
d'un coup juste avant que ne
retentissent les trois coups un jeune
homme franchit l'avant scène monte sur
l'asean et sort d'un sac bleu un
mégaphone rouge visiter écrit
il y a dans cette salle une jeune fille
et comme elle ne même plus je voudrais
que tous ensemble nous crier avec moi
marie aime le mari aime le
que croyez vous que la salle fille les
jambes surgissant des coulisses
s'emparent de ce jeune exaltée de 19 ans
se retrouver enfin entre gens bien dans
la direction qu'avait indiqué john
holmes une jeune fille peur avait-elle
compris qu'on aimerait plus jamais ainsi
alors qu'un roi se meurt summer un amour
mais ce que je voudrais que vous
reteniez ce soir de cette histoire c'est
que ce jeune homme avait compris que le
théâtre et la scène sont encore un lieu
où se glorifie l'amour fou
ceci dit quelle galère d'être ici
mon ami gilles m'a appelé il m'a dit
viens faire une conférence aux tadjiks
alors j'ai dit oui et j'ai dit oui parce
que j'appartiens au cercle des décideurs
alsacien à paris faut savoir ça existe
et on a un principe c'est quand il
s'agit de l'alsace on fait toujours un
effort donc j'ai dit oui j'ai un peu
l'habitude des plateaux avec les
différentes entreprises que j'ai pu
créer
après il m'a dit mais tu sais alors j
oui sans savoir
et après il m'a dit mais tu sais tu vas
pas nous parler
d'économie de business de développement
tu vas nous parler de toi
de moi qu'est ce que j'ai à dire j'ai
rien à dire m mais si tu as fait
dailymotion tu as fait apple
il ya sûrement quelque chose qui te
tirer qui fait que tu as diane
entreprises c'est une autre entreprise
sur la rencontre jeudi coûte non je ne
crois pas enfin je sais pas et j'avais
pas envie bon je me suis plié à la règle
j'ai rencontré
yves et yves m'a aidé à tirer les fils
alors ce que je vais essayer de faire
mais je le fais contre un c'est de vous
dire qu'est ce qui m'a amené à avoir une
vie d'entrepreneur et pourquoi cette vie
d'entrepreneur en fait elle est
entièrement reliés à la notion d'amour
alors
quand j'étais petit j'avais un plumier
un plumier en bois et ceux plus bien en
bois je l'avais pas et il était à
l'extérieur
noir et à l'intérieur une espèce de
rouge bordeaux et sur le premier j'avais
écrit une phrase que j'avais peint en
blanc et j'avais écris
parce que je t'aime je voudrais que tu
ailles haut et loin car sinon comment
ferais tu pour être mon étoile
c'est nietzschéen
c'est nietzsche ça me plaisait c'était
sûr non plus nier alors ça veut dire
quoi c'est pas du tout la fusion c'est
la distance et parce que je t'aime je
voudrais que tu sois loin
c'est cette idée de l'amour où on aime
tellement les choses qu'on est prêtes à
plein de sa griffe rice y compris à la
distance
on a tellement envie que l'autre qui est
le quai la chose principale dans l'amour
existe on est prêt à ce que l'autre soit
loin de soi pour que l'autre puisse
exister pour que l'autre puisse
resplendir et pour qu'on puisse encore
plus les mets donc cette liste et cette
idée de distance
alors c'est marrant parce que certains
disent mais ce que tu racontes la
distance avec l'amour mais l'amour c'est
être à deux c'est être ensemble des fois
j'ai envie de répondre oui on voit ce
que fait le quotidien et d'être toujours
ensemble et plus de séparation qu'autre
chose mais enfin tout ça pour vous dire
que cette idée de d'un amour qui se
dépasse d'un amour qui a un idéal d'un
amour qui est près d'un amour qui
regardent longtemps surtout c'est très
important et puis j'avais un jeu avec ma
copine à l'époque on avait un jeu sur le
verbe aimer
elle m'avait interdit de 2,2 de lui dire
je t'aime
moi je n'ai mais pourquoi je pas le
droit de te dire je t'aime elle m'a dit
parce que quand tu dis je t'aime
la seule chose que j'entends c'est le
jeu
et bizarrement la seule chose qui est
importante dans un acte dans une
déclaration d'amour c'est pas toi c'est
moi
et bizarrement la langue française
va mettre une ellipse à l'autre c'est je
t'aime comme si le thé de l'autre
n'existait pas et que le jeu était
tellement important et donc elle ma vie
dit à partir de maintenant quand tu
voudras me dire je t'aime tu vas me dire
je veux m
cette idée de l'amour qui va vers
l'autre cet hymne est cette idée ça
rejoint un peu cette phrase que j'avais
sûrement plus mais et puis on s'est mis
encore à
chercher avec avec et puis si vous allez
sur apple j'ai un profil puisque je
regarde un peu ce qui se passe sur mon
application et vous verrez que ce que
j'ai marqué pour me définir c'est une
autre phrase et ses phrases existe
depuis mon enfance et elles sont
toujours présentes aujourd'hui vous
allez voir comment je vais les relier à
ma vie d'entrepreneur
j'ai eu une autre phrase c'est c'est
celle qui est sur mon profil d'apple
c'est l'homme labyrinthique ne cherche
jamais la vérité mais uniquement son
ariane
alors il ya plein de sens à 100 il ya le
chacun et chacun voit midi à sa porte je
veux dire on n'a pas tous la même vérité
on n'a pas tous la même femme on va
aimer c'est les choses sont différentes
donc c'est une place appel à des notions
de respect à des notions de différence à
des notions de tolérance
il ya aussi des sauts des décences
encore pu encore plus vieux encore plus
profond le le midd ariane c'est savez
c'était these je crois qu'ils étaient
allés combattre le minotaure le
minotaure c'était cet homme avec une
tête de taureau est en fait sur un plan
symbolique c'est aller chercher au fond
de soi les mauvais instincts le ce qui
est mauvais pour essayer de les tuer
pour essayer mais pourquoi these
ressorti vivant parce que quand il est
arrivé c'était sur l'île de crète dans
le labyrinthe où était planquée le
minotaure il a rencontré ariane et
ariane lui a donné le le fil la bobine
de film qu'il allait pouvoir dévider
pour pouvoir ressortir comme quoi aussi
si on voulait combattre ses démons
intérieurs on avait besoin toujours de
quelqu'un d'autre et on avait besoin
d'amour
je vais terminer avec un dernier truc
puis après je vais aller sur des choses
où je suis beaucoup plus à l'aise je
vous parlais de business de croissance
alors vous allez vous dire pourquoi il a
commencé son numéro avec la petite scène
que je vous ai fait c'est ptet pas une
scène c'est mon enfance
dont j'avais 24 25 ans j'avais une amie
qui était réalisatrice et pour faire une
chez plus loin un petit film que j'avais
fait je devais passer un concours avec
une scène que je devais présenter
parlant d'amour et c'était celle que je
vous ai fait là donc j'ai pas eu besoin
de l'apprendre et les revenus de mon
enfance bon il est quand même un petit
peu répété mais c'était vraiment tout ce
que tous ces gens dont je vous parle
c'est des choses de ma vie et puis à une
bataille alors bataille
c'est un philosophe un écrivain il ya eu
plusieurs d'ailleurs barthe batteur
c'est marrant parce que ces deux
écrivains que j'ai adoré quand j'étais
jeune et bart et bataille quand il parle
d'orgasme savait de quoi il parle
de petite mort
et l'expression avoir un organe ça se
dit en littérature vivre une petite mort
moi c'est 8 c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup interrogés
disant par ailleurs à droite et à gauche
des choses sur le sujet j'ai lu un truc
un jour qui m'a vraiment interpellé
un auteur d'ailleurs bataille encore
disait en fait le jeu amoureux
c'était le jeu qui permettait de lutter
contre la mort et il expliqué ce moment
il disait en fait dans la mort qu'est ce
cas d'envoi sans dans la mort ce qu'a
d'angoissant c'est que à un moment donné
dans notre vie un moment donné on ne
décide pas il survient un événement
majeur qu'est la fin de la vie c'est une
angoisse incroyable je marchais si ça se
trouve je vais descendre et une crise
cardiaque mais mme faucher
c'est une angoisse incroyable était ce
qui se passe quand on vit une angoisse
comme ça quand on vit une angoisse comme
ça
on essaye par mécanisme de défense de
créer des jeux qui reproduisent un peu
séché main comme ça dans ces jeux
virtuels on se prépare à lutter contre
ce qui peut arriver dans des jeux réels
la mort étant la réalité et le jeu
virtuel qui reproduit la mort ça serait
l'amour et pourquoi ce serait l'amour
parce qu'il ya une chose d'incroyable
dans l'amour c'est que on aime quelqu'un
mais du jour au lendemain l'autre peut
nous dire sans qu'on l'ait voulu c'est
fini
et donc il ya un rapport comme ça entre
l'amour la mort et l'amour qui est
absolument incroyable et c'est pas un
hasard si à chaque fois qu'on a une
jouissance on vit une petite mort alors
là il ya eu beaucoup d'explications
là-dessus - celle que j'ai retenu c'est
de dire
pour lutter contre l' la mort
on essaye de reproduire un mécanisme
qui est semblable c'est celui de l'amour
celui du verbe j'aime
est en fait à chaque fois qu'on va aimer
on va vivre une petite mort et en même
temps on va lutter contre la mort est en
fait
c'est quoi faire l'amour c'est pas
simplement avant un bain organe s'est
aussi créé la vie
est en fait ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre la mort
c'est d'être en permanence
dans une volonté de vivre incroyable
c'est d'être dans le vert en faire et ce
un mois c'est ce qui guide talons et
disait que j'avais fait cinq plateaux
alors c'est vrai que j'ai fait beaucoup
de
de choses aujourd'hui avant de prendre
le train hier soir j'ai dû arrêter était
une heure du matin cette nuit je crois
que j'ai envoyé mes premiers mails 5
heures du matin
et j'ai sept vit en permanence alors
on construit des entreprises avant de
construire à peine j'ai construit
dailymotion avec deux autres deux autres
associés qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'elle est
la force qu'on a en nous qui fait qu' on
travaille dix huit heures par jour qu'on
est prêt à remuer des montagnes pour y
arriver c'est je peux vous dire que on
voit souvent le côté bling bling de
l'entreprise qui grandit
derrière il ya il ya un combat il ya une
faut déployer une force une énergie une
volonté qui est quand même incroyable et
bien moins c'est un petit peu le chemin
que j'ai fait grâce à mes deux amis je
crois que si je suis arrivé à être un
entrepreneur qui se bat comme ça comme
un diable
c'est parce que j'ai une volonté d'aimer
une volonté d'aller vers l'autre une
volonté d'exigence une volonté
d'ouverture qui est juste extrêmement
forte donc ça c'était la première partie
des choses que je les vous faire
partager avant de parler d'apple nous
faire passer un petit film je vais quand
même vous dit vous raconter une autre
chance sur dailymotion et vous
connaissez tous dailymotion
quand on crée une entreprise d'abord on
sait jamais congrès de succession ont
créé une entreprise on travaille sur un
bon travail sur un projet on a des idées
etc par contre on a des visions et on a
envie de faire quelque chose alors je
vais vous dire une chose que peu de gens
savent c'était quoi l'envi dailymotion
l'envi la démotion et vous allez voir
que ça a pris un tour complètement
différent derrière c'était on s'était
dit alors je vais essayer de retrouver
la phrase la vidéo est au 21e siècle ce
que l'écriture est au 19ème siècle ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'au 19ème
pouvoir s'exprimer il fallait savoir
parler pas c'est de savoir écrire et
nous on est arrivé à un moment où chacun
dans sa poche un téléphone et ce
téléphone là et bien il permet de mais
de
participer à la vie et donc chacun
d'entre nous peut être acteur de la vie
en filmant et on a dit on va mettre à la
disposition des gens un outil qui va
leur permettre de s'exprimer c'était ça
la volonté dailymotion au départ et on a
eu des des histoires incroyables gens
racontaient un peu à y croire l'autre
jour on a eu par exemple la première
vidéo qu'on a reçue d'un campus chinois
c'était juste extraordinaire quand on a
vu la vie d'étudiants chinois qui
mettaient leur guise sur dailymotion et
que nous on découvrait on a eu des
témoignages comme ça il y avait là aussi
vous voyez une volonté d'aller vers
l'autre une volonté de partage qui était
absolument incroyable alors j'ai quand
même avant de passer un petit film une
question à vous poser donc je veux voir
juste des mains se levaient qui ici a
déjà été sur un site de rencontre s'est
inscrit sur un type de rente
bon y'a pas beaucoup savez ce que j'en
déduis qu'il ya beaucoup de monde off
vous
m
que
à
e
alors apple la bonne c'est donc une
application de rencontres qui qu'on a
créé il ya un an qui marche pas trop mal
on est présent aujourd'hui paris londres
new york chicago et los angeles mexico
je vous en passe ça va vite c'est une
magnifique croissance je voudrais
essayer de vous parler de la rencontre
et du digital
qu'est ce qui se passait avant je vous
ai dit j'ai vu très peu de mains se
lever
j'ai vu que qui est déjà allé sur un
site de rencontres très peu de gens
disent oui et c'est normal parce que la
perception qu'on a des sites de
rencontre c'est que si on va sur un site
de rencontres on est juste un looser
êtes vous et vous av
en fait comme ans était perçu les sites
de rencontre avant nous
c'était chronophage parce que il faut
passer des heures à remplir un profil et
c'était très souvent déceptive
traiterait déceptif parce que une fois
qu'on a un rempli le profil on commence
à utiliser les outils de recherche de
l'autre les outils de matchmaking etc et
puis on rentre dans un chat et puis un
jour on arrive à un deuil tu es le jour
on a un deuil catastrophe la personne
elle a 20 ans de plus ou 20 kg de plus
que la photo ça arrive pas toujours mais
surtout c'est pas ça qui fait kiffer le
qui va faire l'erreur c'est aussi le
procès ce que vous avez engagé entre le
moment où vous avez cherché le profil et
le moment où vous allez vous faites la
rencontre c'est un procès sous vous
idéalisez la personne que vous avez
rencontrées et donc quand vous allez
dans rencontré qatar
nous quand on a réfléchi à aa faire
cette application on s'est dit il ya une
chose qui est évidente il faut ramener
la réalité dans le monde virtuel de la
rencontre et la réalité c'est quoi la
réalité c'est les gens qui a autour de
soi la réalité c'est les gens que l'on
croise ses des transports amoureux de
libération il ya les gens qui ont tué
huit ans comme moi et je suis sympa
savent qu'il ya 20 ans dans libération
envoyez la petite annonce j'étais dans
le métro je t'ai vu je t'ai fait un
sourire tu m'as fait un sourire j'allais
parler badaboum théâtre station les
portes se sont ouvertes a disparu et ben
avec apple cette personne là on la
retrouve c'est en même temps ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que quand on va
ouvrir l'application apple en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben on va
retrouver tous les gens qui a autour de
nous ce qu'on a tous ceux qu'on a
croisés mais vraiment croisés donc si
vous aviez à peine ici ce soir eh bien
vous pourriez tous vous retrouver parce
que vous seriez sur la page de l'autre
après c'est les mécanismes classiques
d'essayer de parler et c'est pour nous
c'est ce que j'ai on a mis dans ce film
tout commence dans la réalité apple
s'est retrouvé les gens vous croisez
sait on veut réinsérer la vérité et ce
sont les codes de la mobilité c'est une
application les codes de la mobilité
rapidement c'est quoi ces simplicité
temps réel instantanéité immédiate et
aujourd'hui être les mobiles on s'est
habitué à une consommation des choses
qui est une tombe consommation
d'immédiateté il ya 20 ans on discutait
à quelqu'un on voulait savoir quelque
chose il fallait rentrer à la maison a
consulté son en cyclo aujourd'hui on
prend son téléphone et on a la réponse
et c'est ce mode applicatifs cet adn
mobile de simplicité eh bien c'est ce
qui modifie le monde aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui va modifier le monde de la
mobilité de demain vous verrez comment
les choses vont se passer mon choix des
projets extraordinaires et c'est la
manière dont nous on a essayé aussi de
modifier le monde de la rencontre je
crois que j'ai largement dépassé mon
temps ils sont en train de hurler je
m'arrête bonne soirée